I think we're at the point in this
symposium where we're starting to
develop some productive conflict and
discussion which I think was exactly the
intention of the symposium this next
panel is composed of a kind of a wide
variety of people with very different
points of view so this is the this is I
guess in a sense where the rubber hits
the road because they're all architects
they're all architects or architectural
scholars so the discussion is going to
turn back towards one with a more
architectural focus hope of hopefully
synthesizing rejecting conflicting ideas
about what we've heard over the last few
days but also adding even more to the
table as I mentioned yesterday and the
day before this isn't a symposium where
we're trying to get any definitive
answers in fact we're just looking for
not the bonfire to warm ourselves around
but embers to take with us and perhaps
nurture nourish in different disciplines
in different ways so with that in mind
Michael speaks has generously agreed to
moderate this panel which I thank him
immensely for Michael speaks is the Dean
of the School of Architecture at the
Syracuse University previously he was
Dean of the College of Design at the
University of Kentucky
from 2008 till 2013 he has also taught
in the graphic design department at the
Yale School of Art and the architecture
programs at Harvard University Columbia
University the University of Michigan UL
UCLA the Art Center College of Design
the Birla Institute and the TU Delft in
the Netherlands he was founding editor
of the cultural journal polygraph former
editor at any New York and former
contributing editor to architectural
record Michael speaks is what one might
call a canary and has been so for
decades within architecture always
seeming to catch whiffs of what was
coming well before the sense of change
wafted over his peers he was
instrumental in the introduction of
Dutch architecture into the American
scene in the 1990s for which we forgive
him
and was equal president
equally president about the end of the
critical or the beginning of the post
critical well before anyone else even
today got the message in 2014 he was
again in canary mode among the first to
organize an architectural symposium
specifically dedicated to
object-oriented ontology at Syracuse
entitled speculations on the real Graham
Hartmann and the triple o challenge to
contemporary architectural several
speakers in this auditorium were at that
fantastic event witnessing in particular
that that kind and well-dressed canary
in fact actually has pointy teeth as he
launched a fierce Mia suey an attack on
the gentle kind charismatic intelligent
friend and friendly but unsuspecting
participants with this history of
foresight and commitment to intellectual
and intelligent discourse pointed or not
Michael speaks is particularly well
suited to moderate the panel the
aesthetics of the progressive
architecture and the state of the
contemporary which is specifically
designed to have a kind of generic
inclusiveness to it to allow as many
reactions as possible to hit the table
please welcome me welcome Michael speeds
back to the Yale School of Architecture
yeah okay thank you very much as
terrific to be here actually the last
time I was here no I almost said last
time I was here it is interesting to
note that the very first installment of
an exhibition I did many many many years
ago in 1999 to Marc's chagrin a big soft
orange happened at the this was the
inaugural year of Bob Stearns sort of
tenure here so so mark is probably very
pleased there's no longer any Dutch
architecture I'm going to present today
and maybe other things I'm I what I want
to try to do is maybe respond in a very
oblique way to some comments that were
made earlier and then maybe more
directly but also I noticed on the on
the conference proceedings that unlike
other moderators I was expected to lead
people in something without having
something already presented to them so
there's really nothing to respond to so
I'll just the rest well I wasn't here
for the rest of the conference so that's
a that's a that's perhaps a problem in
any case I'm what I am gonna do is make
just a few quick comments and then I'll
introduce the the speakers or the
respondents to the to the thing that
which has not been presented but first I
would say it this is a remarkable
conference it's an incredibly eclectic
group of people that you all have
brought together here to talk about
aesthetics
I enjoyed enormous Lee the presentations
this morning and they confirm my
rightness about things I'm going to say
later on so that's the reason I enjoyed
them so much but I also enjoyed them
apart from that I also got to meet very
briefly one of my heroes last night
jacques ranciere it was a fantastic
conversation that mark
scripted and and and participated in
last night the only thing I wonder
particularly given some of the
presentations this morning is that the
critique of expertise and the critique
of the Canon and the critique of
philosophy and the critique of all
things enlightenment has not only led to
liberation and terrific things it has
led to the truthy Trumpy world that we
now live in which is which is dangerous
obviously for many many reasons and so
and so that so that so the ignorant and
and acknowledged ignorant critique of
philosophy wholesale I think is an
ignorant because it is because if you
understand the critique that speculative
realism in general but triple law in
particular is making it is making a
critique of philosophy itself it is
trying to put philosophy in a different
place than it was before and of course
if you admit to ignorance about that you
cannot then critique it because you have
no idea what you're critiquing so let's
just start with that I'm gonna read
something very short not because I I
need guidance but because I write so
beautifully that I can't imagine that
you would not want to hear these first
two paragraphs when Mark asked me to do
this I thought what am I going to say
and I realized this morning I had
written two paragraphs of an essay and I
couldn't figure out what it was going to
go for but I think it's now perfect for
this and I'm gonna share this with you
but but I think it's absolutely right
and everything that I heard this morning
confirms the rightness of what I'm about
to read
no comments yet mark hang on so so today
and I'm also shocked that no one has
mentioned Patrick Schumacher yet but I
will now okay Graham did okay today
no single ideology style or approach no
poetic ISM of the new defines or
dominates contemporary architecture only
Patrick Schumacher principal at Zaha
Hadid Architects
and proponent a parametric ISM has even
made the effort Schumacher may in fact
be the very last of the architecture
Vanguard to voice and answer the call
for the new and that is because an
architecture is in almost all of
contemporary life the call for the new
has been superseded by the revelation of
a reality more complex more weird more
indeterminate and thus more open to the
future than any delivery on the promise
of the new could ever have been from
speculative realism the celebrated
movement in contemporary philosophy
whose adherents confront us with the
strange reality of hyper objects like
global warming so massively distributed
in space and time that they outstrip the
capacity of the human mind to comprehend
to the fashion industry's okage your
embrace of vêtements the outrageously
ordinary and obscenely expensive real
clothes re stitched DHL t-shirts and
wal-mart inspired sweatpants designed by
Denmark as valya head of the anonymous
fashion collective of the same name and
recently appointed artistic director of
the renowned Parisian house Balenciaga
and almost in every cultural way stop in
between including and especially what we
heard this morning the reel has
reasserted itself over the Enlightenment
and has reasserted itself over the truth
in that sense so I would say today we
have no single right we have only one
ideology of the new and architecture
that is that remains and that is
Patrick's and as misguided
as bizarre as it is it's not even true
anymore it is simply itself one among
many competing ideologies of the real so
why is it that we should study
philosophy because philosophy is one of
the very important registers of
contemporary discourse and thought that
is asking us to return to the real so is
it happening in fashion so is it
happening in architecture so is it
happening in many many many many
discourses and so so I would say on the
contrary philosophy is shouldn't be a
leader it is false it is simply one
among many assertions against an
Enlightenment Conte and post Conte and
worldview and an assertion for a turn
not a return for a turn to the real I
would say you know the the Goldsmith's
UCL conference in 2007 which many people
have probably already talked about
featured that Quentin may asou and
Graham Hartmann speculative realism was
launched and then very quickly probably
died as a thing but it launched a lot of
very exciting thinking it to the world
what it did for ARCIC why is it
important in architecture because
architecture from the 1960s through the
1970s and 1980s and 1990s and still in
many places was dominated by the
linguistic turn by the turn that Charles
Jencks and Robert venturi and Denis
Scott Brown and many people including
Peter Eisen and many people who've been
through an electorate in this building
they created a paradigm through which
one can only view architecture as images
at his representations architecture was
inaccessible as the real it displaced
phenomenology which should have been
displaced but instead of replacing
phenomenology in a naive realism it
simply gave us another filter through
which to look at architecture to see to
view to experience architecture and
what's important today about speculative
realism and about triple oh and about
the work of myasu is that they are
asking us to rich are there they are
they are asking us to follow a parallel
you're not asking us we are following a
parallel track in many other disciplines
and discourses to the one that they are
pursuing which is to return to a belief
in the access of the real that's I think
that's I think that's that's why so that
that's why we need to look at philosophy
so the very things that Jonathan
criticized philosophy for having no
access to or in fact enabled precisely
by and are parallel to the very critique
that speculative realism is making of
enlightenment philosophy itself I would
say someone could clap for that if they
wanted to thank you okay just just so so
how did this happen in architecture we
have you know the emergence of this
linguistic model in the 70s and 80s we
have deconstruction as a philosophical
kind of overlay in architecture that we
have shield illusion the work that many
people in this room had some interest in
and with a leverage of Francis Bacon let
us see into another slightly
post-linguistic view of the real but it
did admit only crack the door we didn't
get fully fully fully into that um one
of the things that I and this is maybe
what what Mark was talking about earlier
I've been disappointed that in
architecture we have not taken up the
speculative we have taken up the realism
bit but we have not taken up the
speculative so much it hasn't been
developed the the real that might be
accessed from speculative thought I
think has not really emerged but the
real the return to the real or the
interest in the real has certainly been
dominant in the last three or four years
in architecture Remco houses 2014 Venice
Biennale
it's called fundamentals who would ever
have imagined that REM coolhouse of all
people would be interested in returning
to the essence the truth the
fundamentals of architecture that's an
interest in the real the Chicago B
anomalies in 2015 was a turn to develop
a platform not to feature star architect
maybe not even to think to future
architects at all but to feature
practices the assertion is that practice
is in a sense the new real 2016
selection of Aravena first as a Pritzker
Prize winner also confirms this as does
his 2016 Venice Biennale entitled
reporting from the from the front
reporting what reporting the reality of
the world that has not been acknowledged
by the Venice Biennale to this date and
reporting on that yeah so so so we have
seen this return I think to the real in
in many many disciplines in architecture
included we see in art and we will see
on this panel and I think later on today
one of the more concentrated of what's
like focus areas of this return has been
through triple o and it has been has
been that this discussion has been
engaged by mark age four to Colette on
Michael Yan by a number of people last
night Dean Burke at dinner before
welcoming everybody making comments we
were hearing a lot of hubbub outside on
the smoking part of the apartment they
were all CyArk people she said we've
heard I can't I don't want to hear
anything more about saiyr a lot there's
a lot of them there's a lot of CyArk
interest let's say in triple o and
Graham Harman has is is there right now
I want to ask her not about that later
on why is that why is that because
triple o is interested in among other
things as you've heard already the weird
reality of objects of a real access to
objects that withdraw and that that
appear that the pull away that's not an
interest in the new that's an assertion
or a reassertion of a world of the
upside down maybe of a world that we
that that was there that was perhaps
there all along but we couldn't see it
because we were
looking through linguistic glasses and
we were looking for content and post
content glasses so I would say today
what we see what we have and what we see
in the world is really the end of the
enlightenment the end of any kind of
call for the new and the struggle among
many many many many reassertion Xand
assertions of the real and that is
really that that's the ground that is
the plane on which I think all of the
discussion and debate has is occurring
today I think that would I think would
be on that ground that one could make a
critique of a triple o of speculative
realism of many many many other things
but you cannot make the critique of
philosophy wholesale unless you
understand what velocity its critiquing
and it is critiquing itself and I think
that's a really exciting thing that's
happening right now in fact
weirdly one of the things actually at
the very at the beginning of the session
we were serving what you were serving
those French drinks that have a number
in front of them and I had a number of
them so I don't remember the number now
but as those were being served I got to
meet jacques ranciere and Peggy Deemer
was chatting with him and Peggy said
Peggy was asking about Louie altos air
and about what what the break was like
with Louie Altis air over many things
but over particularly over his over the
sixty-eight response to the students I
was trained as a commie I was a student
of Frederick Jameson's I wasn't out to
serían at one time and loved all that
stuff and was obsessed with it and read
read reading capital over and over and
over and over and and I too
not two parallel run sears break without
a seer but of course we all broke with
Altis air but one wonders in the trumpet
truth the world that we live in now how
wise it is to completely give up on a
distinction between science and ideology
yeah what I think we need is a new kind
of science we need a new kind of a new
reconfiguration of rethinking of what
that might do have that kind of mode of
thought might work and I think one way
for architecture to engage that could be
to take up a speculative side of
speculative realism but but today we're
probably not going to talk about that so
what we will talk about or what they
will talk about because I now have done
my bit I have two questions two
questions
big questions which I'm sure they won't
be able to answer but I'm gonna ask them
anyway how today in architecture in art
in philosophy in whatever in activism
how do we speculate how do we think
about what's possible without turning
with let's say while considering but
without turning our back or turning
towards again the universal truths of
enlightenment modders modernism how do
we think how do we speculate without
returning to the nostalgia of the new
the nostalgia of utopianism I know some
of you probably love utopianism I will
argue with you about that if you would
like how do we also navigate the turn
towards the real without wallowing and
the ninety realism the naive assertions
of authenticity and without the ambition
to really access the real real which is
impossible yeah how do we do that how is
that how are those two things possible
those are big questions for architecture
for the conference for art for everybody
we have maybe more specific questions I
will I will pose to the to the panelists
but before we do so I'll have to
introduce them although Mark asked me
not to read from the prepared
biographies that he gave us so I just
rewrote those on my own paper
I'm not reading from the ones that he
wrote I'm reading from the ones that I
rewrote which are actually better anyway
so I'll introduce first the first
speaker whom I know very well I love
this guy Hernandez Alonso he's a
director of CyArk as of 2015 it's a
practice called spy wrote arc 2005
winner of the ps1 competition in New
York the MoMA ps1 2012 educator of the
year and a guy super super smart but
always tries not to reveal it yeah
that's mine so this is I have a little
personal tag with all of them Lydia call
a political ability traders in engineers
PhD from Princeton assistant professor
now at at RPI she was previously at
Cooper Union and in her biography I note
that she does not mention that she was
at saw at Syracuse before uh I would
think that was a kind of a Princeton
thing because I really don't like
Princeton or Princeton people period
except except Jonathan put it on his bio
so it's not a Princeton thing it's just
Lydia didn't put it on her bio Lydia was
at Syracuse for a while let's just say
that's my personal tag on Lydia yeah she
also was engaged in the Eco Redux
project which is amazing project I saw
her work I didn't tell her this last
summer at the Shenzhen Biennale which
was really incredible and I maybe we
could talk a little bit about that Jason
Payne whom I really like because last
night he looked at me and said I love
that jacket but he also said that's
because I have one just like it
that's Jason Payne it
he's an associate professor at UCLA as a
principal of here suta 2006 MoMA ps1
finalist he has incredible taste you
would have to love him only for the
title of his last couple of projects
raspberry fields and rawhide I I can't
say any more than that Rhett Russo who
was uh was at our conference that that
mark alluded to earlier that we did
maybe two years ago he is the
undergraduate chair at RPI he his office
title is specific objects so he is
really gonna have to do a lot of work on
this panel he's exhibited work at many
places including other objects in
Rotterdam and for that he's going to
really also have to do some explaining
to mark and to me so we'll see an Albina
Geneva whom I was the only participant I
have not met but we met last night and
I'm very thrilled to to know her and to
know her work I knew her work but I
didn't know her she's visiting professor
I believe it prints in this semester
she's director of the Manchester
Research Center she has done two books
that run that kind of stretch the range
of this conference politics of design
practice which i think is super super
important and one of the really defining
features of some of the territory today
where the real is being claimed and
reclaimed practice is more important
than architects and the making of a
building I should say politics that
design practice is 2017 is it out yet
it's well this is only 2016 I guess it's
not yet it will be out next year and the
making of the building 2007 which is
fantastic and she did an incredible book
also an OMA which I have read so those
are the panelists I will ask them to
come to the front now and they can start
by saying anything they want but I would
love to hear them answer some of my
questions please come up does this work
you guys have a technology problem here
just working okay okay so maybe it will
start work how long do we have 45
minutes this is a valuable non shy group
I probably don't have to say anything
more but I will actually and maybe I'll
just start and ask because actually some
of these some of these participants were
at a conference we had this last year at
Syracuse I'm just getting it in Syracuse
last year and we actually had a
discussion about some of these some of
these ideas visa vie the Chicago
Biennale from that had just opened them
people many including Patrick Schumacher
were criticizing many things about it
but I wonder if you all agree with
anything I've said and if you don't if
you don't really care what I said that's
fine but maybe you would have something
to say about where do you see where are
me right now because the subtitle of
this is contemporary or it speculates
about where we are in contemporary
architecture practice in a way we are in
architecture I think in as disparate a
place as the as this conference because
there are big anchors in the conference
there's this there's that there's that
but there is no clear sense of what this
conference is has been maybe after the
fact that what it will be about but
where do you see us right now and do you
agree with anything I say and the more
you agree with what I say that the
happier as a moderator I will be red yes
anything how do we speculate without the
Enlightenment or sort of relying on
enlightenment a sort of philosophy can
you hear can you hear right because I
can't
you guys would not work very well as
spies you're right
sorry right this better yeah this feels
so uncomfortable but okay yeah anyway I
actually don't think we're really able
to speculate at all without
acknowledging that we're in a kind of
enlightened territory to begin with I
mean the the work in the last panel
session that was identifying the sort of
GPS environment that we exist in as a
kind of state of all all presence all
the time I think is a really interesting
one and for me as a lately and certainly
in respect to this conference one of the
thing that's been on my mind is how do
we begin to shift a kind of educational
paradigm where the real becomes actively
participant both in this kind of big GPS
Network live State as a material
condition but also as something where
things like history and things like
design are actively coming at us as data
and as kind of fields of information
that we set through not as a kind of
neutral repository but the space of
actually working so in one analogy I'll
give to this and sort of why it's been
on my mind has been my kids involvement
in Pokemon go and the sort of really
weird
strange things that being within that
connected network and being within a
kind of world of information has given
certain people the kind of empowerment
to go out and actually discover
architecture and see the city in ways
actually understand the city through a
are equally at the time they're not able
to understand it
through a map and I find that incredibly
fascinating incredibly an interesting
place to start to think about spec
elation but I also found in the last
panel two incredibly interesting to
think that something like a Hawaiian
Punch bottle could be something to
change or you know when you're talking
about the punch bottle becoming the gas
mask the kind of weird possibility that
philosophy in particularly kind of
object-oriented approach is something
that allows us to begin to understand
that those objects exceed our
expectations they're full of chances and
that education should really be a way of
investigating that kind of space whether
it's the context of Technology maybe a
kind of high art or hide enlightened
position or the position of the Hawaiian
Punch bottle I think that dichotomy as a
form of speculation where it's a kind of
equally flat ontology is a beautiful one
and a one where that's the kind of real
space that we're worrying at the moment
anybody want to pick up on that well I
would just make this is more of an
observation than any kind of grand
answer to any of your questions but but
mentioning that the Hawaiian Punch
bottle it's occurred to me recently and
it's especially poignant in this place
with this with this conference that the
that that those of us wherever we are on
the kind of spectrum of practice those
of us who wound up for whatever reasons
even committing ourselves to the design
of objects specific objects is the most
kind of perfect named example but those
practices that have been doing that for
some time seem to but but were relegated
to a kind of an underground at least I
kind of felt that way this seems to not
be persisting that that relegation and
there's a certain I wouldn't call it a
celebration but interest in a renewed
interest in those that develop objects
so that's it that's a very specific kind
of observation I've had over the last
couple of days
that's new to me it's a you know it
hasn't been the case for really as long
as long as I've been practicing that
there would be some sort of this kind of
focus on those kinds of practices again
you know however far apart the practices
may be knowledge the practice may be
yeah well I agree with you practice is
the new real this is not this is not
enough all right so I agree with you
practice is the new real and there were
a number of philosophical frameworks not
just oh oh which have invited us to look
at the real and this has started long
time ago I would say and I would not I
don't want to advocate any of those
particular philosophical frameworks as
being more suitable or less suitable for
explaining architectural practice of any
architectural work indeed it's the
interest in the real that matters as
opposed to critical interpretations the
back to the kind of sublime and hidden
rationality behind the design creation
and all this kind of discourse that we
had so practice is important but
practice I agree with you that the other
thing I agree but the rest I don't
disagree that there is a danger need to
fall into a kind of naive interpretation
of reality but there is equally a danger
or in naive kind of empiricism if we
study architecture objects or
architectural practices but there is
also the danger to kind of very easily
take concepts from here and there
because they're fancy because they're
trendy and to take them into the field
of architecture claiming that we explain
something with those concepts whether
it's a spec speculative realism or or
networks or or I don't know black boxes
or
or quasi objects or whatever is on the
table or whatever is 20 we cannot take
those conceptual frameworks and concepts
or notions in the field of architecture
and architectural practices without
thinking what is it that we take what is
the nature of the transportable and
whether those concepts and frameworks
are able to explain anything in
architectural practice and can help us
to grasp this reality and richness of
the architectural processes in a better
way so we have to be very careful what
we transport how we transport it and to
be also very critical in terms of
understanding the explanatory
explanatory force of those concepts and
and and theoretical frameworks that's
another danger I would say and this is
some more it this is I would say more
dangerous than falling into the trap of
naive realism or naive description of
reality and there was a lot of
resistance I would say in architectural
scholarship to go back to practices
describing practices is naive no one is
interested in model making or no one is
interested in how architects draw let's
look at a big concept of networks or
Falls and let's try to conceptualize
architecture practice there was a lot of
resistance I would say 10 years ago
towards this ship to reality towards the
shift towards architectural practice but
I would like to end and the
practitioners know this better than me
but I would like to go back to the theme
of activism it's not working now we have
to if if you allow me to do so because I
think there is an interesting an
interesting concept here and many
interesting ideas that have been
discussed in the last two days on
activism and and I would like to put
this on the table that there is a
different form of activism that emerges
in
architectural practices very different
from the kind of activism against
politics would be clear the kind of
organized activism which is pretty much
related to this to the relationship to
environment that architectural practice
was facing in the last few years as
David Roy he's probably not here you see
I was very rightly saying a couple of
years ago architecture was completely
designed there was not interested in the
issues of environment you were saying in
2013 and architects with the issues of
global warming and climate change
architects were forced to engage with
the environment more and more and if
even if we think about this problem of
environmental engagement what we see in
architectural practices in particular in
the last a few years is a kind of
activism from within architecture a lot
of a lot of them I would say attempts to
deal with questions of environment by
transforming the environment by
transforming the ways of coexistence of
humans and natural entities or nonhumans
or whatever we call them because because
designers and we have we have seen this
in many practices for instance the
practice of Philly prom with the
climatology interest the practice of
Daly's they did benjamine or undress
hock for instance from Columbia
University the practice of re and
Harrison & Harrison Atelier so we see a
very interesting way of engaging with
nature nature not being a distant object
out there passive silent nature that we
only contemplate because it's beautiful
but it's an active engagement with
nature that questions the composition of
nature the different ingredients the
different ways of
Courbet ation and architects actively
proposed in their practice new ways of
arranging those compositions of humans
and nonhumans new ways of rearranging
the cosmos again cosmos not as nature as
a passive a concept out there silent and
indifferent to our activities but nature
but but cosmos as the ordering of nature
as the active aesthetically and morally
pleasing ordering of things and in that
sense designers and architects become
more and more what I would call Cosmo
political designers they engage in to
this kind of reordering of the
relationships of humans and non-humans
and they offer new practical
compositions new practical solutions of
this question of cohabitation instead of
how how does this relate to Cosmo or to
activism you would say all right yes
Claire are making slightly more pudding
all of what you just said all of those
practices are in the most obvious way
political and politically yes they are
because they are all practices that are
engaged in engagement with the world
well the question on the table or at
least let's say the question that is
being asked is one of the questions is
being asked is is it possible that there
is an aesthetic activism is it possible
so no that is not obviously address of
the practices that you well let me just
that is activism not with big a because
we don't have like an active opposition
against lack the active action against a
political statement or climate change so
architects do not act in a blatantly
militant political way they act from we
deemed by offering those new
arrangements new new spaces of Corbett
ations of humans and natural species
and questioning pollution and
challenging those issues of global
warming and in that sense I think this
is a form of aesthetic activism activism
from within activism that emerges at the
level of architectural practices where
you Wow I have to say that I don't think
that activism is a straight line and I
believe in activism but a more sly
underground deviant authorship that
might emerge if if you allow different
forms of expression in the design and I
I like all these practices and I do
believe that mobilizing our disciplinary
tools towards causes is a worthy cause
nevertheless I think it's it's a much
more complicated realism that we're
discussing and the type of activism that
perhaps we were discussing over
discussions in the last days is it's
really tackling the complexity the of
the vast collection of images forms
objects ideas that we have our
availability with the internet the fact
that nothing is really new the fact that
the manifesto is no longer a radical
form of authorship that can bring ideas
to the forefront and challenge our
normative ways or perception because
everything is out there in this growing
formless he had not informed cloud of
information events and so forth and and
I do believe that when we witness that
and that might be dangerous or
productive it depends on how we see it
it really brings a humility to us as
authors and questions what is the
modality of authorship that we can
engage as thinkers architects and and
citizens possibly and how can we
possibly imagine and this is already
happening and we
in discussions with several of the
people in the conference and others also
that authorship reemerge --is as a kind
of
reappropriation rewriting as a kind of
transformation inversion of value of
facts compiling together where the act
of of copying is no longer radical if if
for done Shaam in the early 20th century
it was radical to appropriate a urinal
and re put it in a different context it
is no longer radical for us today that
we do that all the time it is necessary
we are necessitated to do that and in
that question what is authorship we deal
with partial objects we deal with with
with an idea of compiling collecting and
transforming information to something
that we will make that is no longer hold
and and this is something that really
questions what activism might be in this
framework a lot of practices and it's
not just us on the table or the people
here other people that are not in the
conference have sometimes called this
that post digital era where everything
is available I'd like to offer the term
which comes from my own language the
death of percentage Genesis which is a
Greek word that means virgin birth and
it it really is a it's a story about the
birth of Athena from the head of Zeus
and the idea that creation means the act
of the bringing forth of ideas that have
there not existing in the physical world
and are completely new this is this is
no longer what authorship is today and
that's possibly one realization that
really might lead us to think of forms
of activism that are are more deviant
recursive or sly or chthonic the other
realization and this comes also from
discussions that we've had between us is
that possibly the fact that that
Plec City the idea of of the web of the
availability of everything
simultaneously at the same time the fact
that the map of the internet that was
published in 2005 than one of the neuron
networks but everybody knows this is is
possibly leading practitioners
architects thinkers to withdraw it leads
to a type of closure or containment a
type that as we discussed today we need
to focus on an exercise in a project
that is fundamentally focused on a very
very specific abstract problem that is
unrelated not embedded to the physical
world so as to possibly generate
something that can respond to the
physical world and and this is something
very important i we we talked about this
with Brett and Jason yesterday over
coffee and maybe maybe Tom little was
mentioning something similar in the
discussion yesterday where he said well
we focus on something very specific and
abstract and then we retrofitted for for
human use
maybe this task of closure containment
is absolutely necessary to be activist
or to to really generate any sort of
creative engagement and and I do believe
that the vastness of information that
the whole discourse of complexity that
has eroded and what maybe Michael speaks
is refers to a kind of return or
withdrawal from language is very
important and it really is is a kind of
devolution that we necessarily have to
engage with to to move forward me ask a
question
I knew that would prompt you I never
thought I would say them but I kind of
miss you thank you before you jump into
my mic works
the preemie glitch to be beloved by Yale
I don't know what most people do this
kind of thing which is basically I'm
gonna say whatever I want to say without
really caring that much if you have some
relation where were you asked when other
people talk it because I think that's
what we do in conferences first thing is
nice to see that the winter and the
vegetation of Syracuse hasn't slowed you
down and make you happier and that's
always nice to see a couple of things of
this one I will say is I think you're
establishing your questions I think
they're pretty much I would agree with
that and I will not care no because I
don't care that you send someone because
it's general my overall attitude towards
everything usually I don't care my
people have to say these things and the
reason is what is this I have a normal
faith in the power of architecture
discipline to keep doing what we always
does which is to misunderstand
everything and move on into something
else so I tend not to panic over any of
these issues for the following reason if
we trace and I think Yale and Syracuse
and sorry AG and Columbia every school
have this wonderful archives you will
find a conference like this every five
years which everything is we are in
crisis they go whatever detector we
don't know what to do what is the next
thing we can we come with some
conclusion we all follow it next three
or four years we'll figure it out that
what's wrong and we'll move into the
next one and it's always to the
wonderful misconstruction which is
different than anything with graham an
team that would they would they're very
precise and solid and strange and we
always go and kind of ruin but we really
misunderstood what they do and we
transform into something else so the
first thing I would say is okay is gonna
be fine
we don't need to okay it's no problem a
second in relation to this I tend to be
a man of simple tastes in general so I
like to
I like I like to over simplify certain
things and I think part of it what is
interesting today I think what trip
Paulo and many other things bring to the
table I think is a possibility of the
polemic to introduce new possibility how
to see and discuss things I think we
want to do tests of purities on those
things and someone I think we're on the
wrong track and I think it's a waste of
time and I don't think that's the right
thing to do I think it's the question is
how these things and rabble new
possibilities to think about these
notions I personally think the idea of
speculative realism to me it was an
interesting one and probably it came
from the misunderstanding of my own of
that of that term and certainly will be
more interesting idea of a speculation
more than reality
I really think architecture does best
when I stay out of reality of any form
and shape I think architecture has best
when it became fairly useless I think it
should come with a description what
great architecture is and I know that
many people will disagree on this and I
respect that and I understand that and I
understand that demand and people have
in relation to architecture to don't be
that but I really believe that every
time the architecture tried to became
active in terms beyond their own terms
I think we is when things go wrong and
more often than not these mechanisms of
optimism from my opinion which you know
the humble one by now you understand and
a very arrogant guy which any ignorant
guy is but I will say that this is a
recipe for disaster because usually we
came some excuse for the production of
terrible architecture and in that case I
would be I would be I will represent and
I will try to argue for defense of
expertise I still believe the value of
expertise is not off the table and I
think it will be mistake for all of us
to think that can be replaced that
doesn't mean that the idea of one
endures in multidisciplinary
collaborative I think that's terrific
but those words when they're multiple
expertise coming in conflict when you
try to become a generalist yourself for
me to meet us again it's a recipe for
disaster and the last thing I will say
is if fascinating how architect or
unlike any other creative discipline I
can I can think of which is in many many
way at the moral core
a religious discipline and is built on
the fundament of timeless and duration
we are the kind of the most
irresponsible consumer of tendencies of
any kind of influence and we have you
know we keep sort of doing more or less
what we always do but with a different
kind of flavor so to me all these things
are to say the less extrange in the
context but not in any kind of
sophisticated Asaf occur where I'm just
doing it straightforward strange in the
way that my seven-year-old kid will say
strange not in the way of the
sophisticate philosophical things that
many other people are bringing to the
table so in any case my whole point is
I'm not really worried about any of
these things I understand that the level
of my cart is full of love and
generosity these days so I think we're
gonna be okay we will be okay the
conference around Cosmo politics and she
said no I don't want to talk to
architects and why we said she said
because architects theory for breakfast
and I don't want my theory to be eaten
by architects and I agree with you that
there are lots of lots of tendencies and
trendy philosophical concepts out there
and this this also worries me that well
the question for me is how inclusive we
can be how but that's the power of a
researcher his weakness of insecurity as
it disabilities what make it powerful
most insecure discipline and we always
look for validation with other business
that's what makes architecture so
powerful and that's what he makes so
many people who are not our key
to be interesting and engage with us but
it doesn't happen the other way around
which is a bit was an idea I mean yeah
we don't get him by the philosophy
school to talk to the philosopher or to
art school or to science schools or
anything so we are very generous and
ignorant discipline now we are
interested and weak we are weak which is
make is what immigrants they laughs and
the ultimate human is endeavor and
that's why I think I've checked or has
that to me is weaknesses is his power
which is embrace what worries me is that
we are very inclusive and very receptive
to all these new theories as you say or
new trends without having enough time to
absorb them and to make something out of
this that we can take back to
architectural practice no one ever no
one ever does I think he's absolutely
right if you look for example at the way
that that let's say the work of Jacques
Derrida was was consumed and
regurgitated in architecture the most
interesting aspects of that were not
completed by architects who actually
understood the work of Jacques Derrida
so for example we're not Jimmy's parc de
la Villette is the most perfect
expression of the construction and
architecture but it's actually boring
and terrible Eisenman's fundamental
misunderstanding and miss reading of it
is infinitely in my view more
interesting now this is a this is a
theory this is a theory that's her nan
is subscribing to this is actually an
old-fashioned literary theory model
developed by a very famous teacher here
Harold Bloom and so in stone
yeah I guess the point is
you're not making a naive post or untie
our ethical argument to argue that it's
that it is more productive to miss read
theory and to reproduce it in fact
there's no I wanna [ __ ] theoretical I'm
just stating a fact I'm not doing it I
know I know no no I wanna be above it's
you but you're right I'm doing a
speculation aren't you stating a fact
this is what we do they disciplined us
collectively and individually it's what
all disciplines do but fair enough I
mean I just may I ask may I ask and of a
general pressure we'll start with her on
because because I'm thinking back about
Lydia's Lydia's assertion about new
subjects new subjectivity zand and
activities but the way in which the
subject has been reconstituted to think
about activism a different way it's hard
for me to think about activist practices
without thinking about one of the words
got inserted into and we talked about
this last night and we both agree that
we will disagree with this the the word
that got inserted into our title which
is progressive now what I'm curious
about is is it possible to have and are
all our activist politics automatically
progressive what is progressive now and
what is sci-arc has historically thought
of itself from the moment it emerged as
a vanguard School of Architecture is it
possible today to think of a vanguard
School of Architecture
a school of architecture that imagines
itself not only on the cutting edge but
ahead of that beyond before it is it
possible for a school to think of itself
like that without thinking of itself is
progressive yes I would say it's
possible let me bring this way I think
it's possible than vision I'm not so
sure I I don't think it's important
don't confuse ambition with the results
I think as I'm in school you have to
have our lives our schools I have to
have that ambition to do that now then I
think things our time is more refined
more to steal I would argue that idea of
a vanguard today it's almost impossible
because I don't
there are many forces of resistance so I
think that need to shape into something
else and that's why I think the word
speculative or a speculation has
becoming so prominent about not area the
speculation replace completely
avant-garde when one could argue that it
was a mutation and transformation the
manga now what they do beam progres
fields one again I think ambition is one
thing resources another one I personally
think any institutions of any field or
in levels should have you have to be
based on the idea of progressiveness and
that doesn't mean that you're always
going to be ahead of the curve I don't
think that that coming control and I
think that relates a little bit where
you address when you were talking about
for example if Y for example I will not
say that it's cool to subscribe to one
form of progressive news and so on so if
triple o an extraordinary philosopher
like Graham it's interesting enjoying
say of course we will have interested
now is that's gonna define every inch of
a school no and it shouldn't but any
school that is interested in half
physically conversation has to be open
to the polemic I personally find polemic
more interesting and progressive as a
mechanism to operate now the polemic I
tend to be interested in he had to deal
with a progressive you have very little
to do with conservative kind of a
conservative approach there is a kind of
a conservative polemic to which I find
way less appealing and I think it's kind
of a antithetical with any sense of
humanism so I think yes it's possible I
don't know we can be a time but for sure
the possibility to go for it
you have to be there and you have to
come into it not not so sure whether we
do here Lydia progressive we talked a
little bit about that what is it makes
you I'm sorry what did you say makes me
when you change a title and maybe you
can ask a question on that or say your
thoughts on it but
I don't quite it does it is a term
allied with positivist thinking in a
certain type of political ideology that
doesn't make me itch and as part of the
Trumpy work world that do you describe
as dangerous rightfully so and I'm more
interested in when when you were trying
to identify the features and the traits
of the withdrawal from the linguistic
turn you did use several occasions the
word return and this is something that
that we use we use it several at several
occasions today they return to the real
it's not it's it's the withdrawal from
language is something that perhaps might
necessity necessitate a kind of
devolvement
of sorts so I'm more interested in the
regressive than the progressive but
they're aggressive not being kind of
historically to previous time periods
but another kind of model to perhaps
move or steer towards towards the future
and I'll speak more to that in a little
bit but I was interested and this is
kind of not entirely answering the
question of the progressive but it does
we did have a discussion on a dinner
table two days ago about the idea of
beauty that was suggested through Elaine
scary's talk on Thursday and what what
is what are different perceptions of
beauty and if possibly we can identify
ideas of aesthetics that are unrelated
to health or unity as was suggested two
days ago and I believe it was Timothy
Morden who came up with the term a halo
of disgust which we all found really
really productive that something
beautiful has always a margin fringe of
disgust around it and
this is not obviously this is just a
dinner table conversation but it does
mean that anything that moves towards
the future and necessitates this kind of
regression is is really forcing us to
retreat from once expectations and to to
really infuse aggressive ideas in it
ordinate of the progressive I my
immediate image in my mind it makes me
itch or a little weird it out to the
word progressive I have goose bumps I do
with politics by the way it's actually
probably to do with with my sensibility
to award well let me put it this way
when when that word was inserted and you
mentioned it just now I can't help but
think of the of a graphic image the
Hillary Clinton poster with the arrow
that points in one direction which is
quite adamant quite a nice poster but it
and politics aside who cares for now
about that it's it's not about that it's
rather it's that arrow the singular
directionality of arrow really bothers
me and often when I when I hear the term
progressive being used in common
practice or or in more specific contexts
such as this I imagine that that that
straight singular arrow is attached to
the word progressive it really bothers
me I mean I think in terms of I think
more curlicues really like to drag I
mean I like I like dash lines I like
dotted lines I'd like recursive lines I
like so I wonder if and you know
regarding I want to try to link this up
actually to something that Hernan was
saying about the five year period of
kind of anxiety crisis and everything I
actually don't
I usually agree with you err none but I
in this case feels like a very
comfortable interlude
to me it doesn't feel like so I'm sorry
if I'm changing the subject now
progressive but and progressive practice
but it feels like a very comfortable
interlude and a productive one for its
comfort so I don't sense crisis I sense
a certain kind of I wouldn't call it
unanimity but a certain kind of
consensus that and now I'll speak
perhaps but a kind of consensus that the
digital project or whatever you like to
call it somehow
at this point passed several years ago I
think but that we're in kind of thinking
period doesn't bother me at all and you
know the way designers think is often in
their studios in their practices you
know producing things David rhew said
something very interesting and and one
of those questions that's going to be
bothering me for like more than a year
just last night or the night before you
said that trip low will likely provoke
multiple forms of making I mean that's a
near quotation I think what does that
even mean before the practitioner like
inside the studio that's um a very
myopic kind of person often and so I
just think you know what does that even
mean for inside my own studio anyway I
have no answers to that but I would I
would reiterate that question as one
that seems fundamental not just to this
panel but actually to several of them
and quite frankly I don't know that any
of us have answers to that
I have very personal answers that are
going on in my studio right now but it's
not particularly relevant I don't think
to the others so I don't know how to how
we even answer that question on a larger
level at this moment in time we're
passing it around now that's around
it's just like a bottle of beer the
progress question for me is also
problematic and I think primarily
because I sort of have a similar sort of
reaction to the kind of materialist
tendency to sort of be a kind of
judgment of that certain things are
progress and certain things aren't and I
think part of an aesthetic life and an
aesthetic practice for me has been
always about finding those things that
actually may recede from progress in
some way hide or be cryptic or be
invisible and that there is some part of
being aesthetically active which is
about uncovering those things and I
think there are places for me where
architecture becomes the most cryptic
and and and mysterious and the way that
it does that are places where those
kinds of inversions take place not only
in terms of the way the building is used
or conceptualized but the way it's built
and and these things are in some way
antithetical to modernism I think that
that that there's a kind of mystery in
things or there's some some deep sort of
underneath submerge thing in objects and
for architects that for me that have
been able to maintain that kind of
revolution in their work and I always
saw it as a kind of not a reactionary
position but a way of engaging a much
broader set of realities let's say that
a builder could come into the middle of
the process and change the building
himself in some small way that's an
interesting possibility that
architecture holds and would not fall
within the realm of progress it would
form in the realm and in the kind of
opportunity that architecture offers
that I think hernán spoke about I want
to make one just a point of agreement
and then
I know there I see Peggy wants to ask a
question and we have we can maybe take
field a few questions okay but I just
wanted to make one observation and agree
with Jason on this point about the I'm
gonna agree we chase his disagreement
whether or not what this means I'm not
disagreeing with it or not I'm agreeing
with Jason's disagree whether or not I
think I think we're not I think this is
this I'm going to agree with your sense
that this is not a radical break people
are not wringing their hands and people
aren't worried and it's precisely
because and this is what brought up the
question about progressive progressive
means or it's kind of an MSNBC way to
nomenclature to describe all of the
things that are good now that we don't
know what we should be since we're no
longer left or whatever that was yeah so
so when that whole enlightenment
worldview disappears help then do you
what markers do we use to decide what we
agree with and what we don't agree with
and the fact that what no one is
interested in now is the next new thing
means to me is a clear indicator that we
are absolutely post-enlightenment in
that sense and that's why words like
progressive don't make sense to describe
that reality anymore so and for me
that's why this why whatever competing
view you may have it is somehow post or
anti-enlightenment of some in some kind
of way and it is also soft it makes
appeals to the real and Lydia is quite
right to say that I slipped and said
return to the real I didn't really mean
that I meant a kind of an assertion of a
real that maybe was there all along that
we didn't see anyway I'm just I I think
we're not at a bright moment and I think
that's because we're at the end of the
new we're just an assertion of the new
maybe and that program that progress in
progressivism
is part of that discussion I want to go
to Peggy because I know she she had a
question for you or did I did I
misinterpret
okay oh I didn't say I wanted to add
that we also need to integrate better
this the existing scholarship past
scholarship in architecture practice for
instance if we if we think about the
shift from architectural products
towards processes and practices this had
happened in our discipline in the 80s
with the work of donald chong and the
work on reflective practice with the
careful ethnographic description of
architects at work of Dynacraft in the
80s again so this shift towards the
objects towards architectural practices
and practices the new real has already
happened in a way in our own discipline
so we don't need oh oh oh oh eh or NT to
tell us how to look well of course this
provides a new and fresh look at
architectural practices and architecture
objects but we have to take it by also
considering the existing scholarship and
the existing interesting processes and
practices so here you're arguing for one
version of the real and triple o and
that here so that are arguing for
another and I think that's that's just
that's clear that for me the real test
case for you would be whether you can
acknowledge somewhat like like a firm
like you in studio as a firm that
shifting the nature of practice because
they've gone from a firm that's known
primarily as producers of shape and form
in a kind of a formal language to one
that claims to be defined by the DNA of
the knowledge that they produced inside
the firm that leads or does it lead to
discrete to buildings or to other things
Peggy do you need the microphone it
won't work so you may as well just for
you but just to pick up on other ideas
of the real I mean I think you're
particularly talking about the return of
the real but but I think the resonance
that the real has for many of us is
allocating one and the Lacanian one
actually suggests that the real is what
we are
able to organize in our linguistic
framework and pops up despite our
attempts to you know in our epistle
article framework to organize everything
and so examples of those things would be
nine eleven oops
popped up wasn't in our framework didn't
work for extent oops
popped up was in our frame where sandy
Katrina popped up those are the real
those are the reason the return of the
wheel is associated with that is because
it's all related to repression all these
things that we repress that don't fit
totally into our world come back up as
the real they're real I think many of us
think about the real in that way and I
know that that's probably not but I
think a lot of you are using the term
with a cachet that comes from that
Lacanian gazecki in relationship to the
attack on projective okay because I
think in some way what he was suggesting
is that if we don't actually acknowledge
these suppressed things we're not
lettering into the Canon and not letting
into our institutions and not saying
apart in the architectural discipline
are going to come back and be the real
so why don't we actually talk about them
now I think it's pretty interesting but
but one other thing is I actually do
think that one of the things that make
Arctic Tori and ontology appealing to
all of you is because it stays within
our comfort zone it's like finally we
can just think about the object cuz I've
always just want to think about the
object so let me off the hook and let me
think about the object it does seem to
me that we want to think of philosophy
and probably return the real in the
Kenyan sense in a way that makes us
uncomfortable with what our norm is
precisely do not I do not and I don't
speak for anybody else but it is a
precisely against a Lacanian Church of
the real remember
when he said the unconscious is
structured in the most radical way like
a language it is precisely post Sicilian
linguistics that this interest in the
real is is engaging so no we don't want
to be reinterpreted in into the Lacanian
church of the real the imaginary and the
symbolic no it is precisely not that it
is post after and go away with that so
in order to invoke that is to invoke a
kind of what I'm sorry in order to
invoke that as to it is to is to argue
for a kind of language of repression
that believes that you can access that
and get to something really really
really true which just is not the case
you're on board Tom kidding me it
doesn't work I just want to say
something about this idea that that
practice is more real than authors that
idea really bothers me and and I guess I
want to say this about it then I think
that architectural work and
contributions to the discipline happen
in all different levels and I don't want
to give some kind of false hierarchy to
things to say that it practice over an
individual author is somehow has as I
don't know more not just one reality but
more that exists that it exists more
than an individual author I would say
that that authors have Styla that
practices have style that educational
institutions have style and and that
those are real things that that's its
style is a real thing not on the sit
down in the case I don't mean
stylistic but I mean style play yeah
yeah and and I just I want to make sure
I just that was really disturbing to
hear that that somehow practice was was
gonna be of over ordinated over over
over authorship I also I find it
somewhat cynical not not at all you said
Michael just the idea that that that
even within a singular architectural
practice that that its inventions in the
in the realm of form or tectonics or
space or whatever it's doing that those
would somehow be overshadowed by some
kind of organizational structure or some
kind of bin modeling or some kind of
project delivery method or all of those
things that you mentioned in Ben van
Berkel specs it's it it all it all makes
sense and I understand what Ben is up to
but I don't think in any way that
overshadows or is more real than the
work that actually occurs the sort of
strange products that occur in any given
her actus by the way in the urine case
did that may be the narrative but the
war remains looking the same so of
course my point was simply if you're
gonna make an argument for the the let's
say the the primacy of practice then a
pro for then make the argument in the
case of a practice that is really known
for formal expression if you can make it
there then that's a different kind of
argument then simply aren't making an
argument for a practice that is whose
that is defined precisely by his
practice not by its let's say product so
yeah I was I wasn't I was in art hmm
I'm simply drawing circles and saying
that there's things inside them and
inside of one of those circles that is
making an appeal to the real I think is
its practice inside of one of those or
let's say the appeal to practice circles
are next to each other there are a lot
of circles there's a lot of circles a
lot of ideologies you say noticeable
which it will take this is maybe the one
in five years and the whole notion of
authorship also it will be put on the
table in terms of what are the
engagement in today is a fashion house
like
like right now Christian whatever those
that inspire but whatever Christian do
Robbie found around it at one time even
though they became their own brand so is
whatever Christian the old by Ralph
Ralph Siemens which is a very weird
thing you know I mean you have to
outdoors so what constitutes outdoor
today I think it's also called it's a
much more complex discussion and I think
again we're now an unravel here today
but I think there is a whole series of
intersection within that which is a
fascinating subject about where ends
will stops how much and also to me there
has been one of the big big part of the
component of the technology what is the
role of partnership or authorship in
relation to technology in the way that
authors or artists or architect or
musicians operate today versus was 40
years ago the rules are the rules are
profoundly different one more question
mark I know this has been wonderful
thank you guys so much I'm gonna give
Michael Michael the final word but I did
want to make one observation that I
think one thing that keeps coming up in
a couple of these conversations and
certainly an ear question though from
last night or the night before the
worries me is the mentality of what can
I use from this today what can I use
immediately and I've just wanted to
remind at least my students if not
anyone else that it took a good 20 years
to get from Derrida's early writings to
the deconstruction much show at MoMA and
250 years to get from the humanism of
Brunelleschi to the exoticism of a boor
emini and you're talking about on night
one of a conference how can I use that
today is turning philosophy into a
product and turning you into a consumer
and a consumerist agenda for philosophy
and ideas is the most dangerous threat
to ideas that exist today so I'm calling
for a moment and I introduce this
symposium as an invitation to curiosity
that had no claims yet everyone a lot of
people seem incapable of allowing that
to gestate without jumping forward to
the immediate conclusions as to how that
can be active and I would just like to
return to the spirit of an invitation to
curiosity which I think this has been a
wonderful exchange of ideas but not give
the impression that this is a product
that we're gonna buy and pull off the
shelf and if it doesn't work immediately
we're gonna throw it away there's some
fundamental ideas shifting and
philosophy and in all of these
disciplines that I had you know brought
together I could have brought together
others but that are addressing some
fundamental shift in mentality and I
think that's worth talking about I also
think it's worth thinking about and I
think it's worth thinking about for more
than a night so I get the final word
okay I have no real final word except
thank you all for first thing for this
thank you for to the wonderful panelists
and for the water to questions we didn't
have a lot of time for questions from
the audience but the next panel starts
Marc does it start immediately like this
we did sorry okay before my five years
of famer up I wanted to get something
Michael your speech was wonderful I
really appreciate the support you've
given us and taking us seriously really
wonderful there were only two things I
disagreed with with you and I just put
them in in case it helps clarify the
conversation the first design with Tom
that for me practice has always been a
kind of fools gold and I say this with
apologies tell bina and my friend put on
the tour practice is still
anthropocentric right it's still it's
it's a human who's doing stuff instead
of a human who's thinking about stuff
and yes this may seem more politically
progressive because then you can talk
about the handicraft the people who are
usually the subalterns and we're gonna
invert the political pyramid but it's
still anthropocentric and triple o has
been against specifically this reading
of Heidegger which is how Heidegger has
been watered down and his impact has
been overly tempered the other thing I
actually disagreed with is a small point
I don't see Remco houses be an ally as a
return to the real I see as a return to
the basic which is not the real because
the real can also be the compound so I
saw REM show in my terms as a kind of
undermining
that's just a look at arches and keys I
don't see as a return to the real but
that's ok well let that be the end of
you